you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game from round nine the final
round of the 2018 Sinquefield Cup on the
white end Magnus Carlsen and he's paired
against Takara Nakamura this is a
lengthy game a ninety-seven mover and as
one might expect there are many
variations that come from such a game
the more I stared at this one when
preparing for this video the more I
found there's an interesting middle game
tactic also pretty cool
stalemate resource in the end game the
usual case for stalemates anyhow opening
why's what do we have
it is a queen's gambit declined with
move five Bishop f4 LightSquared bishop
s' are quick to watch from the sidelines
black capturing on c4 only after white
has exhausted to move with the Bishop
Bishop a6 is a move not to play if the
black King is still on his home Square
there's a common trick with a capture
and then queen a form picking off the
knight on a6 not the case here but
rather a simple exchange and this is
maybe the first moment that caught my
attention blacks move 11 recapturing
with a bone not a piece why is black
voluntarily breaking the queenside
structure well I believe this is related
to the black Queens mobility black is
anticipating that the Queen will be
under fire with the rook the bishop is
taking away squares well by taking with
the pawn there are now two new options
for the Queen to reliable homes getting
some more development in rooks
contributing light Knight improving
Knights are exchanged white sure's up
the Queen side with b3 also you know
having control over c4 means black won't
be able to get rid of this weak link so
easily each side has a flight square in
the knight on 84 is a strong piece c5 is
a focal point this
host is challenged but these next couple
moves Knights are now exchanged light
focus is on the only open file this is a
strong post for the bishop nice long
diagonal secure square clean is
challenged and maybe this is the first
decision point in the game one of the
key decision points to exchange Queens
are now black is also eyeing up a two
what to do
white says let's keep the Queens on I'm
gonna keep the Queen in the center I'm
gonna take away your flight square and I
might have some tricks up my sleeve
related to the back rank so in the game
we have e5 what kind of trick would
white have if Queen takes a two it's not
some winning continuation but I just
want to give you a taste of how I can
follow up from this position weird
variation kicking off with Bishop e5 the
bishop is poison Bishop on f6 has an
important role defend the back rank
Bishop takes Bishop leads to mate rook
da rook could be for Queen f3 this is
the variation that the computer says is
zero even though White has only a pawn
for the minor piece the rook on c8 is
vulnerable the bishops vulnerable black
King is vulnerable to checks there's a
pin and the black queen is way out here
in left field computer says play rook at
f8 everything's cool okay
anyhow don't have that variation pretty
wild interesting in bounce in this game
it's pawn to e5 Carlsen on move pop quiz
what does white play next feel free to
pause the video okay you ready for this
one
Bishop takes h6 who spotted that if
you're pulling off that move you really
need to see deep
took about seven minutes to pull that
move off Nakamura's reply takes 20 does
not take the bishop rook e8 instead
what's the issue with pawn takes Bishop
one more pop quiz
what would white play next feel free to
pause the video okay well it's a
checkmate in eight
that's how poison that Bishop is rook
takes f7 would follow in additional
sacrifice this is a cool line main
thread on h7 King takes rook is met with
Queen h7 rook d7 and these pieces are
just animals two majors on the seventh
rank in direct connection with one
another tough to parry the main thread
here there is no pairing at mate in five
how bad is it computer says play Queen
c4
that's how bad okay neat sequence chop
and chop black sees this idea rook e8
some repositioning a2 is only picked off
no e four is when I start to think a bit
more about good and bad bishops static
structure bishop is not going to see
along this diagonal if white doesn't
play e4 black may play e4 open up the
bishops eyes open up the rooks eyes to
the e5 square you can see either piece
maybe want to pivot their Queen takes b3
black is up upon after Bishop e3 what
kind of compensation does white have
well very good pieces I believe all
white pieces are better than their black
counterparts in this position
white is focusing on the queenside at
this stage the kingside this bishop
though passive is a very good defender
for the King side so rook b7 rook d6
that is a threat there is a pin Bishop
e7 rook d5 one of these two will fall
white hangs on to the EEP our black
hangs on to the EEP on bishops are
exchanged and we enter a major piece
specific ending Queens stick around for
a little bit
one rook is off and this is where we
have some kind of fancy queen dance not
the most exciting point in this game
king h2 and the rook is gonna arrive on
a6 it's important to make sure this pawn
doesn't get rolling you don't want to
increase this rooks mobility rook on a6
try to maintain that post it has a
wonderful influence on the rooks
mobility and raking in that sixth rank
and many key squares in blacks camp
so this is where we have a little dance
with the Queens not much going on
eventually they will be exchanged so
let's get to that point and we will then
be working with a much more technical
phase of the game the Kings can now feel
a bit more comfortable contributing in
this position no fear of some perpetual
check white remains better in this
position even though it's a balanced
position balanced materially why is
white better short answer more active
rook and this is a case of an active
versus passive rook it really doesn't
get much better than this post keeps
pressure on a couple black pawns black
has to constantly defend some play on
the Kings side and we're soon going to
have a critical moment at this point
right here King g3 move 62 for black big
moment in the game
what is played g5 why is this such an
important moment in the game
well after g5 white plays h5 and this is
a great positive nakamura of course
understands this
he knows that connected past ponds are
very good
why is he allowing that in this position
I'm of course speculating an issue here
I believe black is I think black was
considering playing g5 because he does
not want the white king to get active by
way of g4 and f5 so what am I talking
about exactly well suppose blacks just
sits doesn't doesn't budge with this
pawn this plays rook c7 this is how I
could get active g5 that pawn is pinned
if King g6 King G form h5 takes King f5
this pawn will fall this pawn will fall
soon the black King will fall in short I
believe black does not want to see the
white king get activated in this way
however black can allow this g5 move but
would have needed to see this sneaky
stalemate resource so what is this
stalemate resource
well black can sit away with rook c5 and
not fear the g5 move because black would
be able to play King h5 not g6 but
rather King h5 stopping the King from
advancing and allowing this pawn to be
captured
what's the trick here penny trick would
Nakamura have up his sleeve
after they capture enough six black
wouldn't recapture on f6 this is tough
to spot to be sure black would have the
move rook f7 what's the idea
well suppose the pawn just continues
chopping rook takes g7 check King h3 and
black would have the move rook g3 if the
King backs up the rook just picks up a
pawn goes on to be just to draw and if
King takes rook stalemate pawns can't
move and yeah no legal moves for the
black King black would have to have
spotted that stalemate resource this
this sequence right here kicking off
with g5 he would have had to have seen
he could play King to h5 in me pawn
takes pawn with rook f7 tough spot
okay well in the game black says I don't
want your King getting activated like
this I'm going to allow you to have this
connected past pawn the King side is
officially shut down there's no path for
the king and you know on this wing he
has to kind of go for a counterclockwise
walk so this is what we have King is
heading towards the Queen side and black
with this move
a5 I'm not exactly sure why a five is
played
maybe black just doesn't want to bother
with defending defending defending is
just gonna free up the rook not worry
about giving up a pond and maybe even
another train of thought is you know
what just go ahead take this pawn I feel
that I could defend this endgame and now
that that pawn isn't around maybe the
likelihood of some stalemate resource
later on is that much more likely you
know I won't have that pawn around I
could make a legal move okay black tries
his hand with just giving up the a pond
in short focuses on cutting off the king
and how to free the King well first
Carlsen inserts a Czech king g8 and now
returns the rook is needed in order for
the White King to contribute so the rook
is helping out with this it's helping
pave the way for the King to hang a left
the White King is getting very active at
this stage and there's not much you
could really do about the King getting
into the black position slow steady
progress notice the strong post with the
rook defending f3 securing against file
checks what to do from here
let's see rook b6 b7 check and now the
king is going to slowly try to work
around like that route b1 rook b3 so if
black instead of going for this maneuver
tried to hunt the pawn there is rook c3
to defend so that's why we have rook b12
b3 there is no defense
Zurich c3 King disseminates pawn key e6
material is balanced however white is
better because of the piece positions
the rook is fantastic on the seventh
cutting off the King and yeah this is
super active King there's also a passed
pawn black does not have a passed pawn
so from here rook F for white releases
this connected passed pawn on this move
90 to h6 on board King h8 and this was
an instructive moment for me I was
thinking well I understood at this point
playing king f7 would not be a good move
because the rook isn't eyeing up the h7
squared the king could step up and this
is tending towards a drop pawn is soon
gonna fall so you can't mask the rook so
what I thought is well let's maybe try
Brooke g6 and then king f7 into g6 but
the timing is just not right for that
idea so for example if white plays rook
g7 in this position
black can take on any form and if the
King tries to sneak around like this get
to g6 and then try for this it's just
one tempo sharp you're not able to give
checkmate that's one way to view it this
is probably a simpler way by playing to
g7 in this position right now it's a
demotion of the rook still staying on
the same rank but the rook wants to stay
a bit away from the king white wants to
threaten mate as soon as the King steps
on g6 white wants to be in a position
with the rook to get to this back rank
it's on g7 you're not threatening me so
what is white do here white makes a
waiting move rook b7 so now what to do
if the rook captures let's just pick one
to go with if let's say rook takes pawn
the black King takes here and is gonna
pick off this guy next if rook takes
pawn here it's gonna be mate king g6 the
rook is already in position to give me
what to do in the game it's King g8 now
it's different
only at this point does white play rook
g7 now it's hitting with check that
tempo matters this one key check matters
King h8 and only now does the White King
slip in to g6 there is no time to take
the g4 pawn taking g4 in this position
well there's multiple mates
you could play rookie 7 to 8 that's
clean enough or even in this position
there would be h7 and rook and g8 you
can't take on g4 in the game rook a4 is
played and one final move rook h7 that's
the ballgame nakamura resigns precise
right to the very end I like in this
this check why well you're forcing the
King if the game did continue to ask
where where now it's vulnerable to h7
with check what would be the follow-up
if this game continued again after the
check nakamura just threw in the towel
if it did play out after king g8 the
rook plays - not just any square e 7 the
Queen side is insignificant the idea
here is to stay behind the e pawn it is
past and after you take this pawn
everything's going to fall black would
have to defend with rook e8 King takes
f6 g5 falls the e pawn falls and soon in
the black King will fall why it's going
to have to connected passed pawns black
saw this one coming and simply
threw in the towel a marathon game a 97
mover in a very instructive endgame here
very kappa blanka like i don't think it
was that long ago that I've covered some
kappa blanka games with the rook cutting
off the king very instructive endgame in
this final round game of the Sinquefield
Cup so if you're curious tale the tape
on this one inaccuracies mistakes and
blunders for each side and yeah this was
maybe one key moment g5 not calculating
that little stalemate resource it was
okay to allow white to play g5 but yeah
it was just a growing advantage from
there King heads towards the Queen side
and then up and then over eventually
getting into that g6 square and in the
end of breaking the black king average
sent upon loss of 10 for Carlsen 16 for
Nakamura the final results for the
Sinquefield tournament ended up with
three Co winners Levon Aronian Fabiano
Cara Juana and Magnus Carlsen an
interesting event interesting game a
lengthy one again as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video this
game in the comment section below I hope
you enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or
two away that's all for now take care
bye
you